you know finding the right gift for our
children can be challenging at times
which is why we are teaming up with
amazon to show you some amazing gift
options for kids
these are the tiger and panda echo dot
kids with smart speaker kids can speak
to alexa to play music get help with
homework read bedtime stories and more
while parents have the peace of mind
thanks to easy use parental controls
this is a limited time deal of 34.99
which is a great price for this
and you can get all of that and more
with the echo show five kids and this
has a screen and a camera and kids can
ask alexa to play videos and make calls
to approved contacts and this is a
holiday deal for
49.99 which is also a great price for
all this that you get
now i must say as a mom i can see how
these can make great gifts because
parents can help kids keep learning
simply by asking questions out loud this
will make a game-changing gift to
families
you want to make sure to order these and
get it before christmas because they're
going to run out but
we have a bunch here which is why
everyone in our audience is actually
going to go home with one of these today
thank you for choosing to spend your
time with us today we make this show for
you so
take it with you
[Music]
you